[Music]
with the second pick the Denver Broncos
select Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Von Miller
[Music]
howdy guys this is Von Miller and this
is the Von cash I'm on the bleacher
report app
um you can leave your comments below I
will be answering it answering questions
a little bit later
um but I want to get straight into it
I'm super excited about this week's
episode
um I love this guy man we came in the
same draft class he's done so many
amazing things on and off the football
field Super Bowl champion future Hall of
Famer five-time Pro Bowl quarterback and
he's making an impressive transition
from the football field
to the TV screen he's going to be the
same Richard Sherman that he was on the
football field on a TV screen this
week's episode we have Richard Sherman
how's it going Richard mans but I'm
blessed to be here man I'm blessed to to
get to do what I do man and and you're
one of my favorite guys so you know I
was going to show up man I I appreciate
you bro you know we we from the same
draft class man
um you know I love all the things that
make you special you know I love the
passion that you had on the football
field and you know once you once you
step back and you start doing podcasts
and interviews and stuff like you can
see what makes guys special on and off
the football field man and it's just you
and um it's an honor and a privilege to
have you on how is how is preparing and
getting ready for a podcast and Thursday
Night Football each and every week how
is that for you
right it ain't really no different than
what you're doing now except you're a
little less sore less ice baths less
time at the facility you know but you
you're still watching tape the same
um you're still watching the game the
same you're still breaking it down I
mean whether you're playing right now or
you or you're not playing you still got
an opinion about what's happening about
teams you know I mean you ain't always
public about it but you're like hey I
mean these guys doing well they probably
need this piece right here I mean these
dudes disappointing these dudes just
like they got a quarterback that can
work they just don't know how to work
with him or whatever the case may be so
you're always looking at it at least
from my perspective from a defensive
lens yeah and you're like hey like how
would we attack this dude or how how
much trouble will we have with him how
concerned will we be and how we adjust
and then I just speak on it yeah you
know so I wouldn't say it's more work
it's it's less work it's more fun it's
just when you lead a game when you go to
a game and we we call it we broadcast it
we do all that and you walk away you
don't win or lose so you know what I
mean you take that for however you want
you know I mean you're kind of
unemotional to it it's like hey a team
lost a team one it wasn't unless it's
probably Buffalo or Denver you ain't
gonna feel away about it yeah yeah I I
always because we always talk about
football in and out the locker room you
know and I always talk like with my boys
about you know this team or that team or
this trade which we'll get into or you
know this pickup or this free agency
signing because
I've been playing football since I was
in the fifth grade I've been on a
football team since I was on the fifth
grade so I think it just I think it just
naturally comes with it once you start
once you take a step back your
perspective is is always going to be
about football and what makes teams work
and what makes teams you know not work
so I think I you know I always like to
I wouldn't say it'd be tough but it it
is always a preparation piece that goes
into it and you said you watch film do
you watch your you watch your shows that
you do or you watch your podcast over do
you watch your Thursday night football
game over again and see what you could
have did grade or could it get could it
did better
yeah I definitely do but I also take
outside criticism because you know I I I
I can watch it but it's always tough to
criticize yourself in something you're
not professional in you know we play
football a whole lot so I know what it's
supposed to look like you know I don't
always know what the podcast is supposed
to look like you know I can know when I
tripped over a word or or when I when I
gave a stat wrong or something like that
and I can correct that kind of on the
spot but
um but I I take criticism from the
producers of the show you know from
people outside people friends family and
a lot of times it's positive because
it's just you being yourself yeah you
know I'm giving my football knowledge
people don't want you to you know
there's a lot of analysts out there that
sit there and tell you like hey on first
down they run the ball 15 times a game
and they do this and they do this like
that's not the perspective they want to
hear from us like I played it I'm gonna
give it to you from a dude that plated
do you have like a because I work with
it I work with a guy named Jerry
Madeline have you have you worked with
Jerry yeah I love GMAT man I know he's
gonna see this man I love GMAT man he
always gives you a great perspective on
you know how to be better in this in
this position that we're in now you know
we're not Pros but he is a pro and it's
always good to work with Jerry Madeline
how's your experience working with Jerry
it's fantastic I mean he's he's very
critical and he's very detailed um and
he's very like to the to the T like hey
you're holding your mic too low uh eye
contact don't give too long or you know
he's very specific with his criticism
and it's never personal it's straight
business it's straight hey this is what
you did great this is what you didn't do
great go fix it and I I really like that
man I've heard he's great yeah I I love
Jerry man but you know big day today
big big day in the NFL you know the
trade deadlines coming up and there were
some Blockbuster moves today
um not only today but Christian
McCaffrey to the Niners which I thought
was a great pickup I saw the Rams they
were trying to get them as well but in
that 49ers offense with Debo Samuel
George Kittle
uh ayuk
and they and they have a great offensive
line with Trent Williams and mcglinchey
too
like bro they they are going to be tough
to deal with and you know if you had to
have a knock on Jimmy Garoppolo you say
he he's going through the reads or this
he you know he don't like to throw us
out the numbers or whatever that you got
all these players you just pick one
staring down and throw them the ball man
and you let them work man I really think
you know the um the Debo Samuel the
George Kittle and the Christian
McCaffrey that three-headed monster bro
it's it's gonna be hard to deal with
come late December
it's definitely gonna be hard to deal
with I mean even in the Run game how
Dynamic I mean they can get in the wing
t for all you all that matters and they
still be tough to deal with
um with that kind of talent you know
Kyle gonna draw it up in that defense
once they get Eric Armstead and Ken law
back and they get back to themselves oh
man Jason verret's supposed to be back
it's gonna be crazy man they got they
got Fred Warner I've been a huge fan of
him man they they got a stack team for
real for real Robert Quinn to the Eagles
the Eagles just get better and the
Eagles just get better and better they
already had rushes before so when they
were whenever when I saw like the little
rumors about them looking for a rusher I
was like wow like y'all got Hassan ready
y'all got y'all got sweat you know you
you got Brandon Graham you got Fletcher
Cox like I was already thinking like nah
this can't be right because they they
already got past rushers and then they
went and got Robert Quinn too like you
know the richest get richer bro and it's
just rude it's just rude like and they
ain't just got like password like no one
hit wonder like Brandon and Fletcher
have been doing it since Jesus was a
baby like them boys just eating and you
know what I mean and you talk about
sweat you talking and then you add
Robert Quinn they got old school dogs
these ain't the ones where hey they
gonna get a hangnail or a shoulder gonna
hurt or this and they're gonna be down
like they gonna fight through it and
them boys gonna be a problem in the
playoffs they are going to be a problem
um Derek slay I'm a huge fan of Darius
Slay and I and I still think the
strength of this team is the offensive
line you know they got great offensive
lineman up front
um you know my uh my guy to write my I
forgot his name but I got it right
tackle he is one of them Lane Johnson is
one of the best I probably I forgot
because he he didn't put him clamps on
me so many times you know
I'd have forgot his names but hey Elaine
Johnson is Lane Johnson is not even the
right Taco left Taco he's he's one of
the best tackles in the entire Football
League you know sometimes they say the
right tackle is you know more of a
primary like run blocker man Lane
Johnson he does it all he's good in the
Run he's good in the past and I still
think that the strength of this team is
still the offensive line because they
give they make it easy for Jalen hurts
they don't even have to make it easy for
Jalen hurts but they make it easy for
Jalen hurts you know you got AJ and and
Devonta Smith man they they really they
really have a really really good team
man and the rich just get richer for
sure and he's getting better and better
each week man raquan Smith to the Ravens
that's all they really needed on that
defense it just feel right don't it
that's all they really needed over there
is you know a big Tom inside linebacking
I'm always a fan because I got traded
too I'm always a fan of you know players
leaving teams that they were like the
team were struggling that they were
losing and they go to a team that's
winning you know I'm always a fan of
that I you know you send if you send one
of your star players to a team that's
struggling in the rebuild like yeah I'm
you know I don't like that you know I
don't I don't like shipping guys off for
them to like rot in losses you know I
don't I don't like that so me personally
whenever you see a Bradley chub to the
Dolphins you know a TJ Hawkinson to the
Vikings roquan Smith to the Ravens like
you know they they did they did really
really good by these players this year I
think the chase the chase Claypool you
know to Chicago that you know it's gonna
be a little bit of struggle but honestly
Justin Fields has been coming on like
lately he's been playing a whole lot
better and I think you know a receiver
like like Chase Claypool you know he
could be the spark that'll take them
over the hump as well yeah I mean they
just using him how he's supposed to be
used in Chicago I mean you can't sit
there and watch the dude run 4-4 and be
like hey we're gonna make him Tom Brady
like for what like you're gonna waste
four or four yeah like you know what I
mean like you got plenty of other dudes
to do that why draft him to do that and
then they're gonna say uh Eber flus the
offensive coordinator gonna say during
the buy he's like yeah we watch some of
Lamar Jackson tape and just stole some
of their plays it's like what was you
doing during off season like
did you just realize it was your
quarterback like you know of course it's
working because yes that's what he can
do like but yeah he just got another
weapon you know I think it's a long-term
play for Claypool I think it ended up
being a good fit for him yeah I mean
once you once you draft these guys so
high man like if it's not working just
do what they just do what they was doing
in college it's not you know football is
football is going to always be football
just do what they was doing in college
like that's what you know the Ravens did
with with Lamar Jackson you see it work
and then you just Branch out for that
you know you don't have to try to make
them into these these pocket passes or
try to make him the Aaron Rodgers or Tom
Brady like you just put him in the best
situation and be successful and these
guys are going to make it work they've
been doing it their whole entire life
just put him in a successful situation
and have them run places they're
comfortable with and then they'll make
the magic happen you know I I want to be
a GM like you know after I'm done you
know kind of take like the John Lynch
route you know get on TV and then you
know go be a GM you know that's so I
kind of see it from a different lens and
when you got a guy like you know um
Lamar Jackson or or
um or Justin Fields like you got to like
do what they do best and then you just
Branch off of that of course you know
teams will start looking at teams are
you know try to figure ways to you know
slow these guys down but then you just
Branch out for that and then you just
put a little Wrinkle in it like that's
what that's what coaches get paid to do
you you're supposed to bring the best
and bring the most out of your star
players and you know it's always like
you know seeing teams kind of you know
cater to their number one their number
one picks their quarterbacks these
franchise guys man you got to make it
work for these franchise quarterbacks
for sure no question no question you
gotta do that in general as a coach you
know make you don't don't try to make it
make players fit your scheme make the
scheme fit the players like hey if
you're a new coach and you ain't got the
players that you taught you to have or
the players that fit your skin perfectly
then find a way yeah find a scheme that
fits these players that they can execute
and then you'll have success that's what
great coaches do that's why some of
these young coaches are having success
that's Brian Dabo Debo was like Hey the
stuff he's doing in in New York isn't
the stuff they're doing necessarily in
Buffalo yeah because Daniel Jones ain't
but what he can do with Daniel Jones
General Johnson told it he ain't afraid
to run the ball saquan controlled it hey
we're gonna run this football we're
going to throw it to our play makers
when we can and we're gonna we're gonna
get down the field we're gonna play good
defense wink wink you know wink coming
up with that craziness he was running I
love him he's running Insanity out there
I love wink man I think you know I'm a
defensive ground defense it's a little
bit different you know because there is
no magic call like there there is no
magic call if we got you know if if you
got a 3-4 defense just hoes in a 3-4
defense if you got a 4-3 defense it's
hosing that if you run in cover two it's
hose and cover two if you run cover one
it's holes in cover one if you if you
were in cover three it's holes in that
I'm always on defense I feel like it's
more of a mindset no matter what they
call we got to make it happen and of
course you can always put your your
players in bad situations but really
what it always boils down to is
expressing on defense
what's our mindset going into this game
there is no magic call like once they
see us in this formation or this defense
they're gonna check to something else we
got to make it happen and you know me me
being in me being in the league for you
know 12 years I just I've just come up
with that you know throughout my times
in Denver you know I you know when
you're losing you kind of you start
finger pointing this and that and I just
you know I just take it I just took a
step back to kind of look at it like hey
man like
they got hard jobs just like we got hard
jobs you know defensive coordinators
offensive coordinators it's not easy you
know to go out here and call plays and
you can't put your players in the best
situation each and every time that's why
it's football if if if the offense if
they block
if they block it up exactly how it's
supposed to be 11 or 11 each and every
play that they run on offense is
supposed to score each and every time
it's that one guy that's shed in the
Block it's that one guy that's that's
playing two gaps it's that it's that uh
it's that that cornerback that's
supposed to be on this man but he
dropped back a little bit deep in his
own to be able to help on this seven
route like though that is what makes
that's what makes great defenses and
I've always been a fan of that on
offensively it's a little bit different
you know you gotta you know cater to
your wide receivers and your skill
players and you know your quarterback
went on defense I'm I'm a firm believer
in what's our mindset coming to this
game what are we thinking like how did
we get sleep tonight before we can sleep
the night before that did we do
everything that we possibly could do to
have success in this game and I think
once we start from from that area you
know the defensive calls they start to
open up with the bills we we barely even
Blitz
when you got a a pass rush specialist on
the front side of a run play with three
tight ends and he just pushes his man
five yards in the backfield whatever I
don't know I don't know if you got
special dudes like that then you call
whatever you want it's gonna work it's
it's it's it's definitely you know the
player's man in the mindset going into
it man
um this is this is a crazy day you know
for a lot of these guys man
um but for me a year ago
today I was traded and it was
it it really felt like a bad dream to be
honest and you know I just got off I
just got off the phone with Bradley
Chubb and you know to see him smiling
and see him happy like you know it I'm
happy for him but for me
like I was so invested into the Denver
Broncos like I was so like okay it's not
going good right now but I want to be
part of the reason that we get this
thing turned around like all we need is
a quarterback we're gonna get some more
players like I want to be part of the
solution and I come into work one day
and
uh Vince Garcia I was doing Rehab on my
um on my ankle the hair trainer is Vince
Garcia and Vince said he came into me he
said hey George wants to talk to you
upstairs
and I'm like George wants to talk to me
if he wants to talk to me you know
usually they come downstairs and they
get you and they put you and I was like
is he gonna come down here he's like no
they want you to come upstairs and you
know how whenever it's a move they have
like the little Grim Reaper they have
like the guy like this and he was right
there I don't I don't know his name but
he's he's always there whenever you
trading the player cutting together like
you're like he ain't never here for me
or he was there for me and I got off the
table wrote my heart started beating so
fast like it felt like I was going to
the principal office man and you I had
to walk up these stairs to get to George
Payton office and you know I get up
there I go in the room and George had
like this little button to like close
the door he pressed the button the door
closed behind me he sit down
he first he asked me you know you know
he wanted to know how I was doing how's
my ankle he said hey how's your ankle
doing I said you know ankle's good I'm
feeling all right
say that's good man you think you'll be
able to play this weekend I was like
yeah you know I might be able to play
this way he's like that's good man and
then he just got straight into it he's
like well
took his glasses off put him down I want
to let you know that we are trading you
to Los Angeles Rams and I said whoa like
whoa I get traded to Los Angeles Rams
and I was taken back for a second
and I was like how how are they gonna
afford me they got Aaron Donald Matthew
Stafford Cooper cup Jalen Ramsey they
got Leonard Floyd they got all of these
guys I'm like bro like they got Andrew
Whitworth I'm like I'm not taking no pay
cut I'm like how they go he said well
he's like well we gonna pay we're gonna
pay the majority of your uh of your your
remaining uh salary for this year and we
just want the picks from them and we
want to put you in a good situation to
go in and you know I feel like this is a
win-win for everybody and I was like man
like it just I just felt like you know
because you get so tired to everybody at
the facility from you know the the
equipment guys to the cafeteria ladies
to the to the janitors
um to the infrastructure of the team you
know like we got a guy named Ray jackson
he and he's like player relations and
you know you get used to being around
all these guys that you know once it
once it's like taken away from you like
so quick because in free agency you get
a chance to like you get a chance to say
goodbye you know when you get traded
it's just like boom you get 45 minutes
pack up your stuff that you want to take
now and then we're going to ship
everything else to you you don't get no
chance to say no goodbye
it's crazy it ain't that ain't true that
ain't true huh well I got cut
when I got cut uh in in 17 once you get
cut you only got a certain amount of
time before you could lead the building
so like and you can't come back yeah
it's over so it ain't that much
different so so so they cut you it ain't
even like it was the conversation we had
then walk downstairs try to say goodbye
to everybody real quick and once you
walk out of that building you can't come
back it's over
like and
we different though you know what I mean
because we invested you know I mean we
bought in like we we drank the Kool-Aid
yeah and once you drink the Kool-Aid
it's no I would even take a step further
and say we are brainwashed to to live
breathe Denver Broncos football or you
know Seattle Seahawk football no matter
wins losses no matter what's going on
man and I I was I was all the way in and
you know when that was when that was
taken when I wouldn't even say taken
because I ended up going to a better
situation for me you know personally and
for me mentally too because once you
leave Denver from a losing situation and
then you go to La and I got Aaron Donald
and Jalen Ramsey that Odell came and we
in La like I feel like that really
brought me back like that really brought
me back I always love football like no
matter what even when we was losing I
still love football but the colors kind
of fade a little bit you know it's not
as it's not as bright as it used to be
like it's I still love it but it the
T-shirt was washed a couple of times and
then when you go to the Los Angeles Rams
it's like room you got brand new t-shirt
like I started dressing up for game like
games in Denver I just put on a white
tee some jeans and go to the football
game then you go to La and I started
trying to get fresh and think looking at
my swag and like I'm aware of this like
it just it just rejuvenated me man you
change back on bro change back on like
has it right I'm excited man I'm excited
for to go play football man and sofa
stadium and then you come here to the
Buffalo Bills which the Buffalo Bills
have had for the last two years they've
been the most swaggiest team in the NFL
from you know digs you know the Saran
Neil to even Josh Allen you know he'll
put it on a couple of times too so you
know to come over here and like you know
have like you know this influence man it
really brought me back but it's crazy
because it changes like people don't
look at you the same where you from and
then you go to a new team and the amount
of respect that they show you and the
amount of love you be like oh yeah yeah
I am you know what I mean oh man rich
man I you know I was with those guys so
I'm with the Denver Broncos and I'm
there 11 and a half years I've seen all
these guys come in grow up get new deals
you know I've seen guys come and go like
I was just fun you know I was just fun
walking walking around the facility like
it was just fun which was cool like it
was just fun big bro like fun then you
go to Los Angeles Rams and it's Von
Miller Super Bowl MVP like how help us
win like what do we need to think about
like show us that passwords game that
you that you was doing what are you
looking at in this when we get ready to
play this team and it's just it's just
it really just it really brings you back
man so trades even though it sounds like
you know they're giving you away or
whatever it is man it's when you go to a
good team man it really brings you back
man I'm happy for all of these guys and
who you think really won who you think
really are the winners and losers from
you know the trades we got the Broncos
the 49ers the Ravens the Eagles the
Vikings and the Dolphins well I think
the Niners clearly I mean they got a
little bit of a head start and and got
to see they you know we we got to see
them three touchdowns three different
ways yeah
um and Debo didn't even play so that's
that's huge uh I think Miami is eating
in a big way you know they got their
running back um and Jeff Wilson Jefe is
a really good back and and he's going
back to Mike McDaniel scheme Mike
McDaniels was with him in San Francisco
um so I think the Dolphins is really
doing some some work you know they doing
some work they record ain't the greatest
right now but they got all the pieces
tours playing crazy tyreke's playing
crazy Waddles playing crazy got another
good running back and defensively they
were solid if their Corners both come
back that's a solid Duo you know and
Xavian
um and uh and and and Jones but in Byron
Jones but they did ends you know we're
we're up and down but now they're not
you know what I mean show up is about to
come in there and make a huge difference
and I think that Denver Broncos felt
comfortable with Browning already so
they were like that drive against the
Colts we had that game where Chubb went
out for like two series and Browning I
want to say yeah two sacks two sacks and
a tfl or something I kind of I kind of
saw the writing on the wall then you
know when they see somebody else can do
it yeah and that price lower it's
cheaper and they can do it
get through it but so I think the Miami
Dolphins the San Francisco 49ers the
Baltimore Ravens getting a classic
Baltimore Ravens kind of player you know
what I mean a middle linebacker that can
side behind the sideline you know that's
Baltimore is always known for defense so
I think it's a win for them I think it's
win for Denver you know to get to get
them picks back that they lost trading
for Russ you know they didn't have a
first round and now they're getting the
first round they're back that helps that
team but
we'll see I really don't think that
anybody lost you know I I'm looking I'm
looking at it you know from from picks
and players and I don't think anybody
lost now that the teams win more than
others yes the 49ers and the Dolphins
they definitely won more than other
teams you know I we got the Dolphins in
our division and you know the three
picks that they got from the 49ers you
know they they went and got Tyreek Hill
they got Tyreek Hill with one of those
picks Jalen waddle with one of those
picks and now they just got Bradley
Chubb with with one of those picks and
they were already inside a team you know
Terron Armstead you know he's one of the
he's one of the best tackles in the
league as well two is coming on two it
gets better and better each and every
week this defense is crazy I got to see
it up close and personal uh the safety's
name uh number number eight he
hey um but he is he is really really
good I think he's a second year player
he's really really good I got to see him
up close and personal I think him with
Zay and Byron man they they have a
really good team and of course you know
I get this uh my lenses on these guys uh
you know I'm looking at these guys a
little bit you know more because they're
in the division but you know the 49ers
they want to Debo Samuel George Kittle
you know um Christian McCaffrey and and
um and Coach Shanahan's like you know he
coach Shanahan's like scheme bro like
those two teams especially with their
offensive line over there too have been
a big friend of of Trent and everything
that they do over there in the defense
like you said they get uh you know Eric
Armstead they already got Joey Bosa and
you know Samson oboe cam like they they
have a they have a solid team both for
those two teams they won just a little
bit more than other teams man so nobody
really lost but I feel like those two
those teams won a little bit more and I
don't I don't think anybody's in trouble
either because like you said the Denver
Broncos they needed that first round
pick they needed that first round pick
back they gave up two firsts they gave
up two seconds and three players for for
Russell so they had to like you know
working and like you said you know
Brandon Brandon's been playing he's been
playing crazy they already paid uh they
already paid uh Randy Gregory they gonna
get him back in a couple of weeks they
got Jonathan Cooper he's he's coming off
the benches well he's good they got Nick
Benito from from Oklahoma big fan of him
and they got Brandon Browning so they're
solid Patrick certain
he's gonna be the best corner I I said
this about Patrick certain when he first
came in it's only been two players that
I've ever seen of course I was with the
Broncos you know my my whole entire my
whole entire career until now but it's
only been two players that I've ever
been around that that actually skipped
that that rookie season
Patrick certain and Jerry Judy they
didn't they didn't have a rookie season
they just went straight to year two
those two guys from Alabama I don't know
what they doing at Alabama but those two
guys they came ready to play those two
guys they were never rookies they came
in year two already and you know Patrick
certain it if not by the end of this
year Midway through the next year he is
going to be the best cornerback in the
game just in my opinion
I I I'm not in disagreement I just told
him he got to catch a few more books and
he he owned he owned it um because he
he's strapping everybody he's cut tight
coverage boy that boy has the technique
that they teach like I said his game day
technique you know how you work
technique in practice you work your
pedal in practice it looks so smooth you
look like a drill guy hit a comb bang
I'm doing my thing that boy looked like
that on Sundays like hey how the coach
would coach you to do it in a drill that
boy looked like on Sundays against DK
Metcalf against anybody he dealing with
against Debo like he not tripping Adams
and then he he's he he's a cover corner
he come up and play the run too he come
up and Tackle he's not scared to tackle
he can play in the slot
if when you get a little bit older he
can go play safe he can go play free
safety what like man Patrick Star 10 is
a real deal and I'm happy to announce
that I am the President of the Patrick
certain fan club you know so if you have
any shirts if you ever need shirts some
merchandise just hit me baby I get it to
you man I'm the president of the Patrick
certain plant fan club man and I'm I'm
All About You know getting my dog his
flowers when he need him getting them
the do acknowledgment that he that he's
due man like Patrick sartan is the real
deal man I was I was with the Denver
Broncos for 11 and a half years jury
Judy Patrick certain the only players
that I've ever seen come in and Skip
year one it just goes straight to your
two man those those boys are going to be
good man yeah he's special he's for sure
you know we we played the Packers we
played the Packers this last past week
um and I know you saw the the digs and
and jair what do you think from you from
yo like what's from a corner from a Hall
of Fame cornerback perspective
what do you think is going on what are
y'all now let's not even let's take a
step back from you know um from Diggs
and jair like do y'all really like have
like this back and forth with receivers
are you are y'all really like you know
talking smack during the game I know I
know you are but I just wanted it just
appears
it just depends you know I mean like it
depends who you with who you're dealing
with like sometimes you know nowadays
the receivers want to do their dance and
do their thing but like I didn't play
digs I don't know six seven eight times
um and we ain't never had no
conversation you know other than good
game or good play or you know slap on
the butt and go go on about your thing
yeah but some some guys it's different
you know what I mean some dudes we got
smoke on site and it seemed like I I
don't know how they got smoke on side I
guess they used to be division opponents
but jair played a good game Diggs played
a good game like you get to say that but
when you took the L you don't get to say
as much yeah that's the hard part with
me in the situation like your team took
that he bought though yeah he did his
thing he did but y'all three and five
right now and one team is on their way
Super Bowl Contender they look the part
you just look crazy
it's crazy because rich man I I don't
get trash talk at all like I I really
don't I might get like an extra push
after the play or somebody trying to you
know come like hit me you know a little
bit extra but when it comes to like
talking or like being on something like
disrespectful I never get it like even
in between like you know timeouts or
something like I'm talking talking to
guys asking them about like you know
how's your kids doing like what y'all
gonna do for Halloween you know like you
and Larry Fitzgerald you and Larry are
the only two that don't get emotional
out there I'm not I don't have we don't
have like no no trash talk man I've been
knowing you know I've been around my
colleagues for you know 12 years now man
you know you know a little bit about
everybody on and off the football field
but
you know I I never get it man and I you
know this is a hard game too so I think
on my end I don't I don't give off the
energy you know I know how to turn I
honestly know how to turn it off and
turn it on like I know how to like
say a guy he's doing good or like you
know you look good on family when it
turned off and then just go right back
to to beating his ass you know I don't I
don't I don't I don't have like that
that attachment you know in between
plays you know I did another thing too
this is such a hard it's a hard League
man and I'll be I really be concerned
about guys like mental health man for
real for real and I'm gonna be wanting
to add to it you should you know I know
like it's so many things going on
throughout the week you know you got
families and all type of stuff going on
and then on top of that I don't want
guys to play to a level that they
wouldn't normally play at I don't want
to like boost guys up and have them
going crazy like at a level that they
wouldn't normally play at so I just you
know I keep it cordial man asking for
the kids
first off first off you ain't worried
about nobody's mental health you you
part of the problem some are they weak
you think they playing tackle and they
like man I'm so excited to go again no
they're not you part of their stress of
that week man probably in the first two
weeks
man I just try to I just try to keep it
cool man even like I mean even if like a
guy coming to you ask me like hey man
it's it's your 12th you're like yeah man
it's year 12 man I'm still trying to
kick it man uh you know how about you
man what year is a few is like it's your
phone Hey listen you just keep going bro
you just keep going you're gonna get a
year 12 too man I've seen you on film
man you you be killing [ __ ] man you know
just I just you know keep it cool man
and then like you know offensive lineman
they like to hold and stuff they might
grab me and then once I keep it cool
with them and I'm like hey bro you're
like you hit me in the face like or you
grab me right here what you ain't gonna
do the next play
they're gonna take the hand off the face
they're gonna take that they're gonna
take the hand off they're going you know
what I'm saying so I you know I like I
like that you know I I don't want to
have to you know I don't want to have to
wrestle with these guys all day man you
know I keep it cool man keep it
respectful man
you weren't Larry man you're the same in
that but look at the corner spot like
you it it just it's just you already
gotta be kind of a psychopath to be out
there like not psychopath like I'm
trying to kill everything but psychopath
as in you could be perfect [ __ ] 58 plays
of a 60 play ball game and give up two
plays and you are the worst at your
position to ever play in the eyes of the
fans and the eyes of your teammates and
so you gotta kind of convince yourself
like hype yourself up every goddamn play
like I'm him yeah like I'm the dude you
know what I mean because otherwise when
a good big play happen or you feel like
you out in the middle of the ocean on
the Titanic boy and ain't nobody here to
say and so in order to like hype
yourself up keep you in that mindset you
got to be that that's why you see a lot
of
um like arrogant but a lot of nowadays a
lot of dudes giving each other they
flowers like slaying it started with
Slay Slay Gilmore freaking giving
certain his love giving JC horn his love
giving sauce his love giving giving
Ramsay is know what I mean it's a lot of
that but ain't no love lost between
these two it seemed like yeah I always
like to keep it respectful out there man
and you know I always like to you know
show love because it don't hurt me none
it don't it don't hurt it don't hurt me
none man it don't hurt me none to be
like yeah man he ball out this is and if
you really pay attention to my press
conferences and I know I'm giving a
little bit of my strategy whatever team
that we about to play I say they got the
best offensive line
I just go ahead and say they got the
best offensive line in the league like
it don't hurt me none like I'm not about
to go in here and say man they look I
look like I'm about to get about two or
three sacks this week because if I say
that then they gonna play up a little
bit more man and you know I'll be want
to do that man um we played the Packers
this week you know I was talking to
Aaron Rodgers on there and I was asking
I was like Hey like
why
are y'all not passing the ball like
y'all down 17 points why why are y'all
not passing the ball like
why you're not passing the ball and like
I'm not gonna tell you what he said
because I don't you know I'm not gonna
use this platform to you know to get
[ __ ] started but I was asking I'm like
hey like why y'all not passing the ball
man what you what you think going on not
only well not only thing not only with
Aaron Rodgers but Russell Wilson and and
Tom Brady what you what you think going
on with these three guns no no no no no
no I'll tell you what Aaron said I ain't
got nobody to throw it to I don't trust
none of them I wish I could throw it to
myself that way what he said to you like
I don't trust these boys they couldn't
catch a cold in the snowstorm in Alaska
like that's what he said but you got to
think you Aaron Rodgers like you can't
it's you gotta then you Aaron Rodgers
like you can get these guys you can get
some guys you can get some guys open it
you can tell them little tricks like hey
right when I come off the player action
if you hit this land I'm gonna hit you
right over the front like
getting them open ain't the problem he
hitting them why are they open they
dropping the rock yeah are they running
the wrong route or are he saying run
post and they running Corner are they
saying run to stop they running a go and
then he looking crazy throwing the ball
and he's sitting there sick uh I don't
know what's going on you know I think
Tom you know Tom got a lot of stuff
going on you know what I mean he got a
lot a lot going on it's unfortunate they
you know they always put our business
out there so you can't even just you
know I mean deal with your personal
stuff personally first of all I don't
know like that's that what he's going
through off the field what they put out
there is it's got to be tough to go
through but I've always thought like Tom
Brady
he's able to compartmentalize things and
be able to like especially on the
football field and you know you can't
really live double lives what makes you
great in the football field makes you
great off the football field too so I
would think that he would be able to
compartmentalize and really just put his
craft first but life gets tough at times
you know I can I can definitely you know
attest to that Russell Wilson bro I
listen like
I thought Russ was like the the the the
the the
answer to everybody's problems they
already had a defense
um I like the Russell Wilson pickup you
know if if they don't if they don't get
it fixed by the end of this year I think
next year they'll get it fixed I I like
Russell Wilson in that scheme you know I
think the media they try to make you
know things worse than what they they
really are but I like rush but you you
play with them like what do you what do
you think
they gotta like it's the same with
Fields the same with everybody else you
can't just put anybody in any scheme and
think oh well I'm just gonna make him
fit my scheme like you gotta like it's
almost like they didn't even watch tape
of him in in Seattle and say hey okay
this is what he likes to do this is
stuffy that's like saying hey I know Von
like to rush from this side all right
I'm not even gonna worry about where you
like to rush from all right
yeah I'm gonna put any more I'm gonna
use him how I'm gonna use him you know I
mean and expect him to be effective and
then when he's not effective be like
what's wrong with uh yeah like no it
ain't what's wrong with Von what's wrong
with you Bond rushes from here you
rushing from here he's gonna be the bond
you're expecting to be if you have
Russell Wilson run the plays that he's
run and had success with he will be the
guy you expecting to be but when you run
him have him run offense he has not run
in the 10 years he's played expect him
to to struggle until he figures it out
man Russ got so much control over that
that offense is so much control over
that team Russ you made the Playbook
like let's sit down and do whatever you
want to do Russ like let's whatever you
want to do for us like whatever you want
to do like you show us the way and then
we'll give you our little critiques but
we're just gonna step out the way and
just let you do you like we're gonna let
Russ Cook how do you want to cook what
meal do you want to prepare us like how
do you want to cook it do you do you
want to put in the oven like I feel like
that's the approach that they need to
have and who knows they might have had
that approach but who knows man and you
know I had some more stuff that I want
to talk about man but I know you got to
go man you know I want to respect your
time man it's always been an honor and a
privilege for us to link up and uh and
talk with us on the podcast or you know
out on the street or whatever man I got
a whole lot of respect for you man like
I said I look up to you and you know
what you've done you know post career
what you doing on the football field too
but what you what you've done in post
career too because that's that's what I
want to do I didn't play cornerback but
what you doing now like I can you know I
can see my myself and you and from you
Anthony hawk Hawkins Nate Burleson you
know Michael Strahan man y'all y'all
make the position look very very
attractive man and y'all do a really
good job man and I appreciate you bro
for being on my show man I appreciate
you and I know you don't understand I
have a ton of respect for you and always
have and always will you are perennial
uh uh All Pro or Hall of Famer obviously
you know gonna be go down as one of the
greatest pass rushers to ever put it put
the Jersey on and I'm you know anytime
we come together it's going to be
legendary so I'm just grateful you got
me on which man I appreciate you man if
you ever need me for anything man just
give me a shout bro we're gonna be good
for helping man thank you bro yes sir
anytime you know what's the same
foreign
[Music]